landes comme ailleurs merci la parole
est à monsieur andré schneider hne
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'environnement de l'énergie de la mer
madame la ministre
la production mensuelle d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire a touché en
septembre son niveau le plus bas depuis
ceci est dû à l'arrêt de la moitié de
réacteurs la semaine dernière l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire de monts en aide de
renforcer les contrôles sur six
réacteurs déjà arrêté notre parc de
centrales nucléaires est vieillissant il
nécessite de gros investissements
vendredi dernier dans les colonnes des
dernières nouvelles d'alsace monsieur le
secrétaire d'état à l'industrie a
annoncé je cite le nouveau départ pour
la filière nucléaire
il a annoncé également la mise en
service prochaine de le père de
flamanville nous savons tous madame la
ministre que le développement des
énergies nouvelles ne suffira pas pour
l'instant en tout cas à combler les
manques
faudra-t-il alors recourir à
l'importation d'une grande partie de
notre électricité perdre ainsi notre
souveraineté énergétique pour effectuer
l'ensemble des travaux et df devra sera
dans l'obligation de trouver les
financements nécessaires
par ailleurs madame la ministre j'ai lu
votre communiqué de presse la semaine
dernière prenant acte de la décision de
l'asn
mais j'aurais souhaité que vous
expliquer comment une entreprise comme
edf peut trouver l'argent nécessaire à
la rénovation de notre parc nucléaire
sans que cela entraîne une importante
hausse du prix d'électricité pénalisant
fortement les entreprises et les ménages
or c'est l'état qui fixe les prix
comment entendez vous madame la ministre
résoudre cette difficile équation je
vous remercie
merci la parole comme dame ségolène
royal ministre de l'environnement de
l'énergie et de la mer merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député mesdames et
messieurs les et les députés je vous
remercie de votre question qui permet de
refaire le point sur la politique
énergétique de la france
qui a été d'ailleurs votée par cette
assemblée et donc les réponses à vos
questions sont simples
cette politique énergétique s'appuie sur
deux piliers sûreté nucléaire la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et puis
bien évidemment la montée en puissance
c'est la troisième dynamique la montée
en puissance de la transition
énergétique et des énergies
renouvelables
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a en
effet mis à l'arrêt ou demander des
contrôles sur onze réacteurs sur 58
réacteurs edf un produit son calendrier
de vérification de ses réacteurs et par
conséquent nous observons là d'une part
qu'il y à la transparence sur les
décisions ça a été votée dans la loi de
transition énergétique et d'autre part
que la sûreté nucléaire est la priorité
de ce gouvernement
la seconde chose c'est que nous devons
monte en puissance sur la transition
énergétique aujourd'hui les énergies
renouvelables produisent l'équivalent de
six réacteurs nucléaires
mais vous le savez la loi que nous avons
voté maintient un socle d'énergie
nucléaire important puisque 50% de la
production restera d'origine nucléaire
et par conséquent nous devons à la fois
renforcer cette sûreté faire les travaux
je précise pour répondre très très
concrètement votre question que dans les
factures d'électricité payés par les
français est inclut le coût de
l'entretien et même le coût de
démantèlement des centrales et que par
conséquent cet équilibre qui a été
trouvé par la loi sera mise en
application est une nouvelle fois c'est
par la montée en puissance du
renouvelable par les économies d'énergie
et par la rénovation du parc nucléaire
que nous réaliserons la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui sera
publié dans les prochains jours